foreign
what's up Jordan
how you doing John pleasure thanks for
taking my call you got it what's up so
uh my wife um she started orientation
for her new job she's a nurse so we
needed somebody to watch our
three-year-old while I work on um
between hours and uh we had our
mother-in-law come by and it's been
about six weeks now she's finished her
orientation and my wife wants her to
stay for a little bit longer but in the
last six to eight weeks our bills have
gone through the roof she got to go
dude hey Jordan best of luck to you my
friend
so now my wife is saying that you know
that her job went to the work days for a
few weeks to get adjusted to it and you
know she's off by three o'clock it
doesn't take much time out of my day I'm
pretty much home three out of the four
days out of the week I go to the office
two days a week and you know I don't
know how to tell her hey your mom has to
go because I was you know hey Jordan
what are these bills
um while my electricity bill has gone
from 300 which it averages to 670. oh
gosh how so she's cold she's turning the
heat up
she's homo she's there all day
[Music]
oh man she's turning the heat up she's
eating all the lunch meat
what else
and and the heating bill too so I have
propane Heats on electricity
dude oh man okay can we have real talk
for one second
yes all right so we there is a financial
aspect to this okay no questions I know
I know but hold up when you were dating
your wife
and you fell head over Jordan heels for
her
money didn't matter
you figured it out you had a test coming
up in college I don't care I'm gonna go
see her a Show's coming to town she
don't want to go I'm not going
you figure it out
and now you got mother-in-law there
staying with the family and then these
bills come in bills are real that that's
hundreds of dollars that were not on the
tab just a couple weeks ago and here
they are that's real and
there's something underneath it that's
getting into you what is it
well I for her being here for six weeks
I don't think much has changed you know
my wife has said you know we'll get to
go out we'll uh get to do things because
there's somebody to watch the baby all
the time and none of those things have
happened all right now we're getting to
it do you and your mother-in-law get
along
I
okay let's just put it like hey she's
probably not listening so you can tell
us the truth did she get in the way like
just because it's your house you want to
walk around in your underwear if you
want to because it's my house or does
she get in the way like she's just
taking things upon herself like you know
the UPS guy comes um I run a small
business we'll get mail com and packages
and there's multiple packages that I
can't find because she said she puts
them somewhere and it's not there and
the other day I found two of them
outside in boxes by the office oh by the
recycle yikes okay okay all right so
Jordan here's here's where you got to go
okay
I don't envy you
because at the end of the day you do
have somebody that in their heart and
mind came in to help right and your wife
probably feels a sense of both duty to
mom to give her a purpose and just a
comforting sense that there's somebody
else there watching the kid all that
stuff
I think if you haven't before it's gonna
be the first time you've ever sat down
and not use the word she and them and
y'all but you sit down with your wife in
a private conversation and say me
I'm struggling I feel like I've lost my
house the house that you and I share
that you had higher building
um our bills have doubled if not more so
I got packages disappearing a love and
honor the fact that your mom packed up
and came out here and
I really am I'm feeling less and less
safe in my own house not in a someone's
gonna get me kind of way but like I'm
losing my own home and I don't want to
have another parent in this house and so
give your wife an opportunity to speak
back and because it may be an issue of
boundaries it may be an issue of hey if
there's a package that comes to this
house don't touch it I'll pick it up or
put it right here in this area or
something like that but can he also say
we agreed that this was going to be for
absolutely six months or what what did
you say six weeks or six months six
okay and now how long has it been it's
been we're eight weeks now okay so can
he say hey we agree this was going to be
six weeks and I I was really great with
that agreement but I don't I don't know
how I I don't feel good about eight
weeks or longer yes here's my concern
Jordan
that you've got other issues going on in
your marriage
and I don't want it all coming out of
mother-in-law or wife you seem like a
straightforward kind of guy like myself
and sometimes we can bust in the room
and be like you said that this was only
gonna be like this and now look at this
what are you gonna do like that's look
Jordan that's how we are I'm gonna just
put myself in there that's that's
happened that's how we are we got we
gotta hold back Jordan we gotta we gotta
find our inner John deloney speak to be
heard not so you have uh not be not just
to have said something okay speak to be
heard she sees she also sees that you
know because she's made comments here
and there like the things that she
thought her mother would be doing to
make her life
yeah and maybe you're maybe your wife
desperately wants you to step up and be
the bad guy here and tell your wife I'm
happy to be the bad guy here oh I'm
happy wait wait
Nate John we rarely disagree but I don't
I don't agree well I'm saying this when
I say bad guy I I'm willing to say hey
my my oh yeah you can't you can't tell
me yeah you're right you're right you
can't come that's on me I'm wrong I'm
wrong I don't know that you're wrong I'm
just saying no I wouldn't I wouldn't try
it good call out
Jordan y'all need to be United on it and
at this point
um your wife's gonna have to
be a grown-up too and sit down and say
hey here's in two weeks we need we're
ready to transition and get our house
back we're so grateful for you here's a
really fancy dinner here's a night out
on the town here we're taking you a
Broadway play whatever we want to do
we're gonna do something really nice but
it's time yeah is that going to go over
well with your wife wrap it in a thank
you yep
for the most part
Parts the youngest of eight yeah
where's where does Mom go after this
bought back to Boston
she has a place or she's going to
another sibling
she has a place but she's usually she
she lives in Florida but she spends most
of her time with her kids in Boston and
and it's like her sister lives 10
minutes down the street she doesn't she
doesn't want to go and see her sister
okay
well that's a her issue not you guys I'd
say out of that stuff but Hey listen if
if you and your wife had plans like hey
when you get to this nursing job we're
gonna be able to go out we're gonna have
extra money all that and that's not
happening don't roll all that stress
into this conversation
because it can be real easy that all of
a sudden this conversation turns into a
and you said this and this never happens
and now your mom's here and now we're at
War and nobody's gonna win
let this be about hey want to get our
house back we said six weeks it's been
eight weeks let's count at ten weeks
this is done um let's sit down together
and have this conversation I was wrong
Jay was right don't don't divide it up
um we're gonna do this one together and
then let's have a different conversation
now that she's settling into her new job
now that you're settled in now that you
got your house back what is it going to
look like to have a date night once a
week that's why we work so hard I don't
want to I don't wanna have a one night
one night a month with you one night a
week with you I want two nights a week
with you what is it going to look like
to find Child Care What's it gonna look
like to do all these things to create a
life that is worth living man yeah and
so good for you Jordan thanks for thanks
for trusting us
um you do have to have a hard
conversation but again remember make the
conversation especially initially about
you what you're struggling with what
you're upset with what's hurting you
um not don't come in guns are blazing
because your wife's gonna have one
option that's to defend herself and now
you got world war three and there's no
sense in that I don't envy him but I
think if he wraps it up like you said
wrap the Mother-in-law up in a thank you
thank you for all of this here's a meal
we're so appreciative then you bring the
wife over here and wrap that up in a
nice date and it's like hey I've missed
you like any time look it anytime your
husband or spouse comes at you with the
I miss you I want to be with you I don't
get to spend enough time with you if
you're not melting down I don't know
what's happening to you I don't know
what's happening go go melter like
butter like a hot knife through butter
man we have very different spouses